thank you squarespace for sponsoring
today's video we'll be talking about
them at the end
so make sure to stick around
[Music]
we're going to universal studios
i think ran out of ideas
hello we are where are we
we are at universal studios and we came
to celebrate this little boy
he got honor roll at school so we're
like right you have to pick your reward
what do you want to do
what did you say universal universal and
we're meeting up with our friend
andrew and his little boy ray so we're
gonna have a nice fun day at
play day universal studios hollywood
do it again you gotta fish
[Music]
live long and prosper empty
super empty you left out me
ah wait up
jurassic park meal you need a dinosaur
leg look how huge it is
true yeah
hello all right we're finally here my
boy
let's go hi harry potter world
i forgot what it's called wonderful
wizardy or something i don't remember
but isaac
yeah we've been wanting to come here for
many many years
yeah we were able to go to the one in
osaka
we are now in osaka universal studios
pretty cool that now the first time he
gets to see harry potter worlds is in
japan
how do you feel about that baby that's
exciting wow
look at this hogwarts express
baby i'm so excited for you cool
look at this what is this place called
again hugs me hugs me
harry hi ray hi ray hey
you're about to go you are hairy man you
got the glasses and everything
you're just missing the scar oh man it's
in japanese it's all in japanese baby
that's ron's japanese voice yeah that's
hermione's japanese voice
but now you get to hear everything in
english because it was all in japanese
so it's like a nice things right yeah
what are you looking forward to the most
the ride the rides which one they have
two rides uh
both i want to get a butter beer because
that
was amazing it tastes so good we
actually passed it
back there it looks exactly like an
osaka remember how in the entrance it
was the train
and then the butter beer and then we
keep going and it's the castle identical
it looks just like it but now everything
is in english
i want butter beer all right let's get
butter beer
[Music]
just like in japan you know what i
i like the one in japan better because
they foamed it up like a lot
yeah sure this is kind of weird is the
best part that's good
all it is is just cream soda and whipped
cream
it's like buttermilk all right
butterscotch let's try to smell it
take a sip take a sip
if it's been on a intense
diet how is it gonna get your stuff won
it's good but too sweet for me
[Music]
look greg
all right so his dad and isaac just went
on a ride the harry potter ride but
ray's too small to get on that ride so
we're out here just watching him while
they get on the rides
and so ray's like i want to get on the
road too so then
uncle casey over here starts making a
roller coaster hey
it's the bumpy part
[Music]
careful man he's too short to get on
almost
all the rides here so we're just trying
to make the most
out of having him here you get to like
switch off with the grown-up
okay so now it's our turn
take care of the toddler
[Music]
what's in there right
[Music]
like a whole kitchen here here
[Music]
great
[Music]
please please please please yes yes we
got it yeah we're going on
we're going home
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everything is under control
[Music]
[Music]
once again thank you squarespace for
sponsoring today's video squarespace is
a powerful
easy-to-use platform to create your
website with squarespace you can connect
with your audience send email
communications leverage audience
insights and most importantly generate
revenue if you want to blog
squarespace has powerful blogging tools
to help you build a community it can
display all your social media posts all
in one place
so your followers can easily find them
and share them if you want to start your
own store
squarespace has powerful ecommerce
extensions for you to use
there's new third-party tools to help
you manage inventory promote products
streamline bookkeeping and ship items
across the globe go to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com
tiffanycase to save 10 on your first
purchase of a website or domain
thanks squarespace
[Music]
me